the number that jumped out at me was 10
food at home yeah i mean just the
average american family paying 10 more
to eat at home today than they did a
year ago
uh they cannot sustain that for a very
long period of time and my fear is all
of the things that we talked about
previously around the wheat prices
fertilizer we even got uh in the u.s the
wheat market we started to get some of
the readings and and it's much lower
amounts of the wheat is actually high
quality than they had predicted et
cetera and so you start to like stack
all this up and you're like man if food
prices all of a sudden we get to
12 15 god forbid 20
increase in food at home yeah
that's gonna be bad this is how you get
like like riots and pandemics right like
we're already starting to see it i think
like sri lanka was having protests
pakistan sri lanka the central bank just
uh so they're bankrupt
the the so all right let's go one by one
here so the food thing i think was very
eye opening i was like oh my god like
this could even though it may not have a
material impact on cpi itself if
everything else starts to come down on a
percentage basis and let's just say that
we'll give the uh the the anti-inflation
crowd uh the assumption that okay
inflation peaks in march which
do you agree with or disagree you think
that it's going to peak year over year
it could uh because the base effects
really materially steep in april but
that doesn't mean the momentum is just
dying down correct once you get past the
base effects you're still going to be at
a very high level of inflation that's
the problem with the momentum yes so
that's generally my idea as well it's
like people are going to start to now
just go headline numbers and they're
going to lose the nuance uh and and
going into midterm elections we're going
to have politicians being like
victorious
victorious worth six and a half instead
of and a half you know and and if we
didn't have base effect it would really
be like 12
100 yeah that's the problem yeah right
so uh so i think that's a big problem
when we then go and we look uh around
the world i recently wrote about it i
know marty bent wrote about it a couple
of different people uh is we now have
had two central bank slash governments
however you want to break it down uh
basically say
checkmate like like game over uh without
restructuring because we had lebanon
which for two years now they've been
having riots in the streets the uh the
currency's been devalued significantly
there's been more than 50 contraction in
the economy over the last two years like
just horrible situation for people on
the ground they basically like hey we're
done right uh and now they're coming i'm
like oh we're not really bankrupt but
like you know whatever spin they're
putting on it but like they're bankrupt
sri lanka
which since 1948 they've never had an
issue paying their external debt service
wow 1948 till today never had one issue
they are very unique in that obviously
you get all the undisciplined monetary
and physical policy over the last decade
going into 2020 you then hit the
pandemic pandemic was important for sri
lanka high tourism oh yeah all of a
sudden if they don't have tourism right
gdp all that stuff big issue then they
get all of the uh race between central
banks to devalue their currency right on
a relative basis
then
they get the uh hit of uh the rush
ukraine situation
right and you go step by step by step
and you're like these people just been
throwing curveball after curveball after
curveball and uh i think it was marty's
point which i thought was really good
was he was like look the weakest fall
first and so lebanon sri lanka like
they're not the fed right the fed has
got like all the firepower and these
guys basically are knife fighting yep
the question is
are the two outliers or are we gonna see
more fall and again they won't be
western developed nations where most of
the people who are watching this show
have to worry about like oh my god is my
central bank going to go bankrupt yeah
but they're still i don't know how many
people are in sri lanka but there's
millions of people that live there
totally right that are negatively
affected by this and so like do we see
two three four five more like how do you
is there a real material difference than
a poor person living on two dollars a
day in sri lanka than a poor person
living on two dollars a day in india
lebanon nigeria morocco like is it
really no
this is the problem and this is this is
why i don't i think the sort of
inflation around narrative on wall
street is missing the point which is
what's going to cause
food and energy prices to stop going up
are we going to get a glut of energy or
a glut of wheat a glut of corn coming
from somewhere anytime soon because no
if we don't the supply and demand will
dictate that the price has to continue
to rise you know to crowd out the
marginal buyer to crowd out the marginal
demand
and so
that's my point it's like we're
forgetting that okay yeah the inflation
might peak year over year for a
convenient narrative in the u.s equity
market or u.s bond market but that
doesn't mean we're not continuing to
build the risk that we see protests
not just in sri lanka but in detroit in
st louis in minnesota you know people
are poor poor people this is really is a
really bad time man hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time